hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are back at the 1918
tournament of New York work of a Blanca
with the white pieces faces wrote the
Honorable Roy Turnbull black and last
time we had mr. black here we used the
photo of the hoodie guys since I
couldn't find a photo of him but thanks
to you guys we were able to find this
very nice photo of him it's not very
nice but it is the one we have we don't
have one of much higher quality but it's
one where from where he was much older
than one where he faces Samuel Reshevsky
but here in the first part of the
tournament as it is a double round-robin
Capablanca drew against Roy Trimble
black it's the only place only game
kappa blanka didn't win so so far in the
tournament all wins and only one rogue
Android terminal black so let's see how
black deals with capablanca with the
black pieces without further ado let's
check it out cup of lanka has the white
pieces and he opens with E for with E 5
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 so the better
of defense and Knight captures on e5
with d6 pushing the knight back Knight
to f3 Knight captures on e4 d4 and d5
all standard as it is played today with
Bishop to d3 Knight to c6 and now comes
Queen to e2 much well today it's not a
move that would be played today probably
some really nice e3 or Knight bTW 2
would be played or just castles but in
those days a queen to e2 was considered
standard theory we have Queen to e7 by
black castles by Capablanca and now
Bishop to g4 just a nice developing move
and the black is without without a worry
in the world
we have c3 as black threatens to capture
on f3 and then well eliminate the d4
pawn as the knight is defending its lock
up a Blanca defends it we have pawn to
c3 castles a queenside castle at that
and the now comes rook to e1 and here we
have f5 and it's interesting this exact
same position since it was played
between Capablanca and Roy Turnbull
black in 1918 New York tournament
never happened before as of course white
a white found better moves to to play in
the opening other than the ones that
were popular in those days with f5 and
now comes
Bishop to b5 you could also try
developing but it's not
not easy to develop you could try
something like that b2b - you can't go
something like a knight at Ford in Joe's
g5 and you really give black initiative
to start pushing and creating an attack
on the kingside as it is a game of
opposite side castles so the first
player to attack is most likely - to do
well so after a 5 we have Bishop to b5
capablanca wants to play Bishop captures
here and maybe just Queen to a6 check
you know see what happens
so Queen to f6 preparing to defend here
but also preparing to bring the dark
squared Bishop into the game we have
Queen to d3 now on pinning and here
capablanca doesn't want a story or a
black doesn't want a couple Blanca -
let's say capture here and then go
Knight to e5 to get this very nice a5
square for his Knight
so Roy eliminates tonight with Bishop
captures Queen captures and now just
Bishop to b6 allowing capablanca to
capture here he's not worried about that
he wants to attack on the Kings side we
have Bishop captures by Capablanca be
captures on c6 a cup of Monica gives up
the bishop pair to mess up the pawn
structure on the on the King side and
now comes Bishop to f4 with rook HD 8
finishing development and not just the
Bishop captures and v6 with deep
rotators and e6 preparing rook DITA east
6 to double up on the e-file and are
just night 2 d2 and here
rogue d2 e 6s planned and here kappa
blanka goes squinted e3 he tries to
transfer the game over to the Queen side
maybe some Queen to a6 ideas are
possible as there are a lot of weak
points on the Queen side and here you
have to decide here black can go for
night capture some d2 and it is a very
nice line Queen captures you can go f4
now threaten f3 and let's say if rook
captures rook at the Queen captures now
he threatened checkmate when you want
would result in captures captures and
not immediately but well if if a capture
if if trade did happen along the e-file
so why can no longer win the e-file but
if the Queen moves then Queen e1 would
of course result in checkmate so here
you would probably play something like
f3 make some breathing room for King
also prevent black from pushing f3 and
it would be well a nice equally game
where I guess black is to be preferred
but I've got a Lanka
so he can always go king of to just
trade everything along the e-file and
play this a kingdom pawn and game where
he does have a bit of a superior pawn
structure and a less pawn islands but
Roy goes for a different line he doesn't
go for the one we've mentioned Knight
captures he goes for Queen to h4
threatens Queen captures here and now
White has to decide what to do here but
he does have to react we have Luke - E -
just defending the f2 pawn and now
Knight captures and e2 and here of
course you cannot capture the night if
you capture the knight then all sorts of
ideas become possible if you capture
with the rook of course than just the
rook e1 ends the game rook captures rook
captures you have to block with the
Queen and then well your ear just down a
queen and losing so after night capture
somebody - kappa blanka played rook
captures on e6 we have rook captures on
e6 and only now Queen captures and e2
and now Roy goes back with Queen to e7
and now it's a pretty much the same
position as the one we mentioned only
this point is not on f4 and at this
point is not an f3
so King to f1 by Capablanca not allowing
any threats along the e-file also maybe
ideas of trading with King - b7 and now
comes b4 now comes the Queen to h4 again
as couple on complete team to f1 now the
H to pawn becomes vulnerable with h3 and
now F for preparing f3 at some point and
here just Queen to d3 not allowing this
pawn to advance any further and here an
important move is Queen to h5 here
although it's hard to say Capablanca
wants to push b5 and here if Queen to h5
then b5 isn't all that dangerous because
now Roy can start attacking with f3 now
the Queen also will eyes the f3 pawn and
now if captures you can go route
captures on c6 the rugby one check King
can hide and now well it's actually
white who has to worry about what's
gonna what's what's gonna happen here if
rukiye one you can just capture here
with check King captures rook g6 check
King to f1 and now it's a well it's very
hard to say if white would be able to
put for anything here if anything it's a
most likely black who would be able to
do it so here Queen to h5 like we said
best idea pretty simple paragraph 5 but
Roy decided to go about it differently
he played the g5 he wants to bust open
the King said completely and he says
Capablanca is too slow on the Queen side
but Capablanca disagrees and he pushes
b5 with g4 black ignores him B captures
on c6 King captures on c6 and now Queen
to a6 chip we have Queen King 37
Malcolm's Queen to b5 check with King
the e7 sink to capablanca okay you can
either capture this pawn I'm just gonna
capture let's say if you capture here
I'm just gonna capture on h3 and then
yeah I mean it's it's it's me who's
attacking it's not you who's attacking
you're just gonna have to settle for a
nice draw here after a repetition of
moves so here after King to e7 couple
Monica says I'm not interested in your
poem just Queen c5 check and now what do
you do now if of course if you go here
then the Queen can grab the d5 pawn with
check so here King to f6 just hiding
that Queen King and now comes not
captures not captures but rather Queen
to f8 check came to g5 and now Queen to
d7 check and now you can either move the
King or block with the rope the problem
will blocking with the rookies Queen to
e5 check King to h6 and now you
eliminate the pawn with check Queen
captures an f4 check if you go back
Queen captures on c7 with check and if
you block with the Queen well then we
white can just go into a are winning
endgame for him as he will be up
material not something black wants to do
so here Roy played King to f5 and now
comes the Queen to f7 check now you have
to block because if you move the king
you're just gonna lose the rook so we
have Queen to f6 but now Queen captures
on h7 with the check forcing a either
the King to move back
but if King here then of course you all
see the one it's actually very very
poetic it's h4 its mate in one
the King has nowhere to go the Queen
guards the light squares so that would
be very unfortunate for mr. black Queen
to g6 just blocking and now comes H
captures on g4 you can't capture with
the Queen because the Queen is pinned if
you capture with the king then again
white can just straight down into a
winning endgame but there's not all
much you can do if just kingi five then
there's no more attacks
what can either just go for the C seven
point so King to g4 was played and now
you could go for Queen captures through
captures and then hope to win this row
component you know where you're up upon
but it's not very likely as Black has a
very active King F sorry f3 is coming so
Capablanca just decides to capture yet
another pawn we have Queen captures on
c7 there's always time to grab one more
pawn you know unless there's not but
here there is we've looked to be six by
black and now you can't start attacking
me it would have three just Queen g3 and
you're gonna again tray down into
winning endgame
so after Queen captures on c7 we have
rook to be six and now Papa Blanca just
goes Queen d7 checked he's not
interested in the a7 pawn king to h4
Queen east 7 check King to g4 and now f3
check with King to h5 and here
Capablanca goes Queen to e5 check you
can also play rook to e1 to threaten
rook the e5 check but again it was most
likely the case of Capablanca being lazy
to calculate rook to be 1 but here you
can just go Queenie 5 10 25 checking h6
Queen captures on f4 you just grab more
pawns King h7 or or whatever and then
you just continue playing the game where
you're just up so much material but
couple Mongkok perhaps he just didn't
you know feel like calculating at Queen
to e5 check with Queen to g5 and now
comes look to e 1 and it was in this
position I know 41 that on Robo Reuter
Trumble black resigned in the game
what if you resign there's no real
counter play here if you trade Queens
just captures you move the King wherever
and then you lose another pawn and then
you're just up three points in a row
component game this is of course
completely winning for capablanca and on
the other hand if you don't capture it
if you go something like king h4 hope to
activate your queen once again just
Queen e2 you're gonna go for some like
king queen f2 check you're gonna go
behind with the rook and it's gonna be a
quick win for white let's say if you try
something like rogue g6 to create
threats against the white king just
Queen c2 I'm making room for for your
rook let's say if if 23
rook to e8 now as planned you have some
check checking ideas from the back would
be very uncomfortable for black and then
if you go back with sequin g5 then just
well we have to check you go back look e
5 again wins the Queen it's only sorry
only one of the lines but in every one
of them capablanca will will you know
end up on top yeah
after Luke to e1 Roy Turnbull black
resigned the game and yet another
victory for Capablanca in this New York
tournament of 1918
so again so far all victories only one
raw in the first part of the tournament
or also again this opponent Roy Turnbull
black we'll see how it goes few more
games in this tournament and then we go
into the match against Borislav Kostich
and then we go of course into the World
Chess Championship match against
Emmanuel asker to end the capablanca
saga and then of course we're gonna
choose a different saga and then you
know enjoy that so that's the game I
would like to thank for free the request
of one tenth our own waffle art Francis
da berry and his sons
Felix Ryan and Kenneth McKay of Scotland
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content continuing the
Capablanca saga checking up in your
suggestions and of course following
what's cool in in in the world of chess
I think y'all I will see you soon have
an excellent rest of your day